Joe Biden's problems just got worse his
son Hunter getting indicted on three gun
charges it's relying on a Federal Form
three years ago while cracked out of his
mind and it's the same firearm that got
tossed out in a garbage can which he
then blamed on illegals if convicted
Hunter could face up to 25 years in The
Slammer and prosecutors hint there could
be more charges on the way it's a real
head scratcher if you take Joe's word
that his son has done nothing wrong
first of all my son's done nothing wrong
I trust him I have faith in him and it
impacts my presidency by making me feel
proud of him this thing about a gun I
didn't know anything about it I've
gained confidence in my son I love him
and he's on a straight narrow and he has
been for a couple years now and I'm just
so proud of him Democrats are relieved
that Hunter's gun charges don't have
anything to do with Joe Biden yet
we shouldn't take Delight in other
people's misfortunes but we have to have
a rule of law and when people
uh
commit crimes then the consequences
follow the justice department charges
have nothing to do with the President
Hunter Biden is a private citizen he is
not the president of the United States
it sounds like a prosecutor appointed by
Donald Trump kept by Joe Biden to
investigate his own son has found that
there's no wrong doing that Joe Biden
did so
um great tell that that bang bang Joe
Biden's other problem that's not named
Hunter is his age and it looks like
Democrats can't avoid that one either
well age is a relative thing as we all
know let's be in the very positive vein
about age it is about judgment and
that's what a president needs to have
Joe Biden knows his why the conclusion
that people draw is I think off base
when people say to me well he's old yeah
that's right but look at what he's
gotten done and then if that's not
enough for you look at the alternative
the White House gets frustrated with the
media for bringing it up but they're not
going to stop it's a water cooler issue
with the public it just is all right
judge gun charges is this all there is
or is there more to come
there is definitely more to come first
of all the walls are closing in on Joe
Biden right now The Dominoes have
started to fall we talked about this
with David Ignatius the opinion piece in
the Washington Post we knew that it was
going to start falling apart and then we
have Nancy Pelosi you know it was a very
smart woman who was able to say very
clearly that you know Joe Biden is the
greatest Kamala is the greatest and
instead she refuses to say that Kamala
Harris is the best running mate for Joe
Biden okay and then you've got Mika
Brzezinski actually saying this morning
that this has now become a real serious
discussion about Joe's age and his
mental acuity okay but now we've got the
first time in American history that a
president's son has been indicted he's
been indicted for something that is very
much a provable crime it is a matter of
record the public record uh he has made
admissions in the book three counts to
this indictment uh adding up to 25 years
however ever those 25 years if he were
to be convicted of all three lying on
the Forum lying to the person who bought
the gun from and actually possessing the
gun while uh he was under
um the influence of drugs uh the
sentence would be the sentences would be
one concurrently that means he's never
going to get 25 years and as a first
offender it's probably not going to be
anything you know even near the highest
charge or the lowest which is five years
however what is stunning about all this
is that there is absolutely nothing
preventing this indictment from being
issued five years ago or four years and
11 months ago the fact that David Weiss
now has special prosecutor status hasn't
given him any additional powers that he
didn't already have because this
indictment is in Delaware where Hunter
lives where the crime was committed and
David Weiss has always had the power in
that particular place now the
whistleblowers are the ones who really
open this thing up to us because Joe
Biden had has been lying and you
actually do get it it's his son he loves
him my son has done nothing wrong we
pretty much expect every parent to say
that kind of thing but this is not the
end of it by any by you know any stretch
of the imagination this is one count
that is just a door opener and what will
come now given the kind of you see
what's happening with the Press now what
we've got are even Democrats like Nancy
Pelosi kind of saying yeah you know who
knows Mika Brzezinski man there's a real
serious discussion the the the the the
flood waters are coming in the next will
be on the tax indictment okay you cannot
do an indictment of the taxes and Hunter
Biden without investigating Joe and as
they investigate Joe more information is
going to come out about as they
investigate Hunter Moore will come out
about Joe now Weiss saying that it was
not his decision whistleblowers coming
forward we've got everything now in a
situation where this thing is all all
you know damn the torpedoes the bidens
are going down we talked about this
yesterday it's just a question of when
all right Dana now on to Joe the cat is
no longer in the on the roof
it's in a shoe box getting ready for
burial in the backyard already and I
think we're seeing the bat signal we're
seeing the bat signal go out to
everybody it's okay to talk about it
yeah they've had that terrible no good
very bad week this week and it started I
think in on Sunday in Vietnam when the
president gave the press conference that
was incoherent Monday he got slammed for
being Alaska on 9 11. Tuesday the David
Ignatius column post which basically
gives the green light to The
Establishment to open the floodgates and
now you have on Thursday the inflation
report and a hunter indictment I'd say
that's a pretty bad week yeah and then
so my question is
um I'm interested in the legal front as
to what's next but also for me
politically what's next so now you have
Joe Biden who will probably go to the
beach this weekend right and or
somewhere maybe Camp David he'll be with
his family
and does he start to make the decision
does anybody start to talk to him about
what we are actually seeing I don't know
maybe he doesn't want to hear it maybe
no one in his circle is able to tell him
directly maybe that's why these messages
are coming from outside and someone
could say sir we really need to have a
serious conversation and does it open up
a position where Joe Biden would say
I've accomplished so much look at all
I've done I've done what I said I would
do
my son is being hunted by the
Republicans and it's unfair and he's in
recovery and I love him and I'm going to
Pardon him and I'm going to step down
from running for reelection that is a
real possibility and something that
would be amazing to cover it also could
be completely untrue yeah I once went to
Camp David but he was busy doing a drag
show
so no one gets that I got it Jesse
I'm pretty sure you could see Gavin
newsom's grinning teeth from the
International Space Station
because of the whitening yeah no because
Biden he might not jump I'll tell you
why I don't know if he wants to LeapFrog
a black female VP he might keep his
powder dry until 2028 remember if Trump
wins it's only one term and let's be
honest if Trump wins the revenge tour
it's going to be tough for Republican to
win after that so Gavin could just keep
his powder dry and wait
um so I'm not sure he's jumping in and
I'm also not sure Biden's going down
he's definitely heading down but he's
not going down without a fight this is
Joe Biden we're talking about the
stubbornest man in Washington D.C it's
going to get ugly so Weiss is his pocket
boy he's still protecting Hunter
I don't think he's going to serve a day
in jail on the guns I think they're just
going to drag it out it's a charge not
connected to the president and they
don't often prosecute this because it's
really hard to prove because most people
don't confess to being on drugs and
buying guns only Hunter is dumb enough
to pull that off so
you're right though now everyone says
it's okay to talk about Joe Biden but
they don't know what to say because in
the Democratic party you have to say the
same thing as everybody else if you
don't say the same thing as everybody
else you're ostracized so everyone's
kind of feeling around in the dark is it
okay if we talk badly about comma is it
all right if we mention Joe Biden's age
and it's fun to watch because usually
they're so militantly disciplined in
their messaging this is they're spazzing
and it's very entertaining
um the bank records are where it's going
to be they're going to go after hunters
and Joe's but the offshore is where the
action is you can move money from an
offshore account to an offshore account
IRS has no clue Comer's not going to
know not even the iOS whistleblowers are
going to find it so you gotta find the
offshore I wish I knew that earlier yeah
right Tulsi I think the real fear is not
that Joe is incapacitated they don't
care as long as he wins they don't care
if he's you know a vegetable they fear
he's going to lose especially it with
impeachment looming what do you think
yeah I mean I think this is even bigger
than Joe Biden that that this is why
we're seeing what we're seeing is
they're saying well this guy could
actually really lose which means the
Democrat Elite the power elite they lose
and so this is why you're starting to
see this little bit of this transition
here will it be Kamala Harris will it be
somebody else but one thing that I
thought was interesting is you know
people are talking about Biden's
accomplishments and in that Ignatius
piece he said Biden's accomplished so
much he's done all these things his
greatest accomplishment was that he beat
Donald Trump right that was that was
like a few years ago yeah and then you
have Hillary saying you know we'll just
look at what Joe Biden's gotten done
well when we actually look at what he's
gotten done the reality is our country
is worse off now than when Joe Biden
took office and there's a whole laundry
list of things that we can get into I've
wrote down about 10 of them
um uh without even scratching the
surface but but most seriously he's
gotten us into a new Cold War and a hot
proxy war with Russia that has increased
the likelihood of nuclear catastrophe we
just saw how he has pushed Russia North
Korea directly into each other's arms
increasing the threat coming from North
Korea directly to the American people
and our national security our borders
have been handed over to the cartels our
cities have been handed over to the
criminals parents rights are being
threatened uh with regard to their
child's education I mean the list goes
on and on uh it's not a hard argument to
make to voters about why Joe Biden
presidency or frankly any of the
Democrats they could pick to replace him
could end up pushing our country to a
place that is dangerously Beyond repair
in there you made that great point is
that President Biden's greatest
accomplishment as president was being
president yeah there's nothing else just
just walking in the door so it's walking
in the door that's amazing he's a lock
on the White House door yeah he's just
keeping Trump out of the white exactly
but if the lock is faulty yeah they're
done what does that tell you about their
priorities though it's like okay well
the American people needs in the economy
and all of these things it's to keep him
out there it's a squad hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else